marit et à monsieur le président ma
question s'adresse à madame la ministre
de l'écologie du développement durable
et de l'énergie
s'il est un principe universellement
reconnus comme justes efficaces c'est
bien celui du principe pollueur payeur
chaque utilisateur de l'opa id redevance
pour financer alimentation nos ouvrages
d'assainissement et de dépollution
cela marche ainsi depuis des décennies à
la satisfaction de tous
mais en impasse budgétaire le
gouvernement vient pop et le produit des
redevances sur l'eau pour alimenter pour
réduire le déficit de l'état vous
siphonner les budgets de l'eau ceci est
proprement scandaleux en 2014 l'état à
prélever 210 millions d'euros sur les
agences de l'eau et de 2015 à 2017 il
prélèvera encore chaque année 175
millions d'euros et en introduisant un
plafonnement annuel il détournera
désormais l'excédent perçues au profit
du budget général de l'état
finalement c'est le modèle français de
l'eau que vous mettez en danger vous
détourner une redevance de solidarité
entre les usagers de l'eau créé pour des
répondre aux défis de la gestion de
l'eau alors si le gouvernement juge que
le combat contre la pollution est
terminée
s'il estime qu'il n'y a plus de risque
inondation s'il juge qu'il n'ya pas de
défis d'adaptation au changement
climatique
alors oui qu'ils réduisent alors la
facture des consommateurs en diminuant
la redevance pollution
mais ce n'est certainement pas l'avis
des comités de bassin kidron des veaux
le font savoir que le gouvernement
français ne fasse pas croire aux
français qu'il baisse leurs impôts
quand il transforme des réseaux leurs
redevances spécifique de solidarité en
ressources budgétaires classique vous
détourner les ressources de l'eau et
vous tromper les français est dans
l'impasse budgétaire vous allez conduit
la france
cela devient une habitude de gestion
taxe chirac sur les billets d'avion
plafonnait fonds national de gestion des
risques en agriculture ponctionnait de
250 millions prélèvement de 1 milliard
d'euros sauf la dépendance autant
d'exemples de cette dérive
alors allez vous revenir à plus de
transparence et revenir sur ces
prélèvements inique
merci la palette à monsieur christian
eckert secrétaire d'état chargé du
budget
monsieur le président mesdames messieurs
les députés monsieur le député à
questions précises réponse précise
avez vous conscience de l'état des
finances que nous avons trouvé en 2012
avez vous conscience de la nécessité de
redressement des comptes publics à
laquelle ce gouvernement a eu à faire
face
la décision est claire tous les secteurs
de la dépense publique sont mises à
contribution
que ce soit les taxes soit la sphère
sociale que ce soit les opérateurs et
les agences de l'état
il en va de saint principe pour les
agences de l'eau qui ont des trésoreries
abondantes
il faut le savoir il faut le reconnaître
et comme pour d'autres opérateurs ou
agences de l'état qui perçoivent des le
produit de taxe
il y à un plafonnement de leurs
ressources puisque vous l'évoquez ce
plafonnement n'est pas atteint
aujourd'hui les ressources des agences
sont de l'ordre de 13 milliards d'euros
et le plafonnement est de l'ordre de 12
milliards d'euros
elles ne sont pas touchés par le
plafonnement mais leurs trésoreries sont
excédentaires et devant si ce type de
situation comme pour les chambres de
commerce et d'industrie comme pour les
chambres d'agriculture comme d'autres
opérateurs de l'état
il est fait appel à la mobilisation des
fonds publics de façon à avancer vers la
réduction des déficits
et puisque vous l'évoquez monsieur le
député le montant des contributions des
usagers aux agences est fixé par les
conseils d'administration
la loi fixe des plafonds et ses plafonds
ne sont pas obligés d'être appliquée et
s'ils étaient des trésoreries encore
excédentaires il y aura toujours lieu
d'adapter comme cela a été fait pour les
chambres de commerce
le montant des contributions au montant
des besoins
mais si la parole est un monsieur
dominique lefebvre